all right people this is the one we've
been waiting for the falcon and the
winter soldier it's two minutes long
if you haven't been watching our one
division reactions go ahead and check it
out because of course we're going to be
covering falcon and winter soldier
after wanda vision's done let's get down
to business
she didn't everybody loves raymond who
would like connection
let's go all right
so
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
will you take up that mantle
ah man it's gonna be crazy
love this looks like oh yeah crazy ass
action movie
oh she back
big game spot right there
[Music]
the choreography looks insane
oh
they keep thinking anthony mack is the
new king of streaming at this point man
that's right it really is okay all right
wow
wow wow wow wow that that really does
just look like a crazy
epic action movie as much as we get like
the buddy cop vibes between the two of
them i actually had the vibes between
their dynamic a little bit more akin to
kind of like
the nice guys more yeah where there's
kind of it's like couples counseling
sort of
session they got going on about you guys
are partners you have to work together
work through this
right now in that sense kind of you got
the a little more of those familiar
marvel comedy
vibes to a certain degree it does look
awesome it looks incredible you get more
shots in here of falcon
using the actual captain america shield
at one point you even see bucky catch a
shield
so i don't know if they're gonna be
actually sharing that shield at times
during this it'd be pretty cool if
you're watching them kind of swap around
with it getting a better glimpse of
sharon carter being back in the marvel
cinematic universe and then of course
baron zemo i mean to me that was one of
the biggest highlights of this trailer
where he's talking about how his work
feels unfinished and he's got his actual
berensing a mask he's carrying it
i'm assuming that's in sokovia and he's
looking at like a mural
honoring his family i don't know though
i mean that statue looked like it had a
mom and dad a daughter and a son
maybe his he built a giant statue just
for him
that was the one maybe maybe you're
right yeah but i was like
this is i mean one division has yet to
wrap up i mean maybe that has something
to do with uh you know the
maximoff or or any other people they
could be related to you never know
i'm so confused we're going with
anything we don't want it
looking at that i'm trying to tell you
who
are you going i don't know i mean
there's stuff that's not been revealed
but either way i don't know i think it's
also two sounds cool because i've heard
anthony mackie i think say that you know
that he's grappling with whether or not
to take up the captain america mantle
completely beyond them being
buddies and having that sort of odd
couple dynamic i imagine there's also
two going to be some level of character
development around who's going to take
up the mantra
and why and i think it just makes a lot
of sense from a character standpoint to
have captain america's like two
best friends now jammed together and
having to jockey for you know the top
position
i feel like with some of the action
scenes it looks like a more
focused stylized hand-to-hand combat of
what we've been seeing in the fast and
furious trailers
but like the marvel level especially
that shot with
falcon zipping underneath the truck
there's action scenes in here the
on-the-road stuff that does remind me
of fast and furious crazy heights level
you got to keep in mind
this is designed for streaming this is
designed for
television so i think they are taking
television to another level when it
comes to what they're doing now and i'm
curious to know
exactly where this play takes place in
the timeline
of the marvel cinematic universe i mean
obviously after end game
it took a little bit of figuring out too
with one division specifically when that
takes place so i'm curious to know where
this takes place and how
tied in the events of one division will
happen with this one because
one of vision looks like it's going to
be changing reality in the future of
marvel for all we know it
where this feels very focused although
there is that line in here where they
say the whole world's upside down
i thought that was just talking post
blip world that they're living in
but maybe when they're talking about the
whole world feeling upside down could be
talking about whatever happens at the
end of one division segwaying into this
which seems likely you know yeah
absolutely i mean you know
even though they do seem so disparate in
terms of their tone and what they're
delivering and this obviously seems very
much more inclined toward
physical action they have to be tied
together in some way shape or form
although i mean this was originally
supposed to come out before one division
before it got remixed right
so i guess it might not be as crucial in
terms of where it lands chronologically
i mean they got to keep everything
really mysterious yeah absolutely and it
seems like they are arcing sharon carter
to be a little bit more
in tune with peggy carter like a
modern-day version of peggy carter to a
certain extent i mean the action scenes
that they gave her here
look straight plucked out of something
out of like uh captain america winter
soldier
or derrick double for that matter you
know and i mean captain america winter
soldier has some of the most beloved
just like
physical hand-to-hand combat stuff and
that really seems at work here
it's interesting that you're getting all
these characters who are within the
captain america world like this is
falcon and winter soldier and yes
captain america
world encompasses mcu world but these
are his peeps these are yeah and you've
got sharon
carter here you've got pal you got semo
these are all characters who were
featured in captain america civil war
like this is when they first shared uh
the same property you know so it is
interesting seeing them all here
honestly i just can't wait to watch a
new rock star's breakdown
because they're gonna explain it all
better where are the roadie clues
all the people with like the masks and
the face painting on them i don't know
who they are
you know with japan are they doing some
kind of crossover event there with
hawkeye or something
the impression i'm getting with uh
sharon carter too is that she's probably
hunting them at first
it looks like they're fugitives and then
eventually she'll team up with him
sharon carter style has established
all right guys well falcon and winter
soldier what'd you guys think of the
trailer leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
check out our wanda vision
reactions if you haven't done so already
do keep a look for when we start
covering this
last but not least
gotta shout my man bradley bledsoe
bradley you've been an incredible help
to us
over the past few months with the
channel in more ways than you realize
i'm very grateful to call you
my friend and recently he told me that
it's official him and his wife are gonna
be adopting and i'm so
happy for you guys already got a kid
picked out
worst case scenario if you don't like
the kid just return it
you know it's just give you a box and
you keep like 30 weeks
and then uh 30 weeks doesn't pan out get
a warranty on the kid yes
if you break the kid then buy the apple
care for the kid so i think everything
will be all right in the end
but it's all sincerity dude
congratulations excited to be working
with you more
in the future uh i know that you're
going to want us to be hiring you
especially now you're going to be having
a kid
now i feel pressured to be hiring you
because you got to take care of a kid
so really your kids are stressing me out
now thanks a lot bradley thanks man we
can't deal with this